welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
boss and doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness has revealed major
clues in promo footage in high quality
versions of the official poster the
lurking demon cathon the original author
of the darkhold the artifact that now
seems to be the key to wanda maximos
role in this film and this film's final
battle on what we think is wounded gore
mountain all of these details that we
thought were just forgotten loose ends
from one division but now upon re-watch
are critical to the biggest crossover
event in mcu history so i'm gonna
connect all these dots well actually
reconnect them because turns out i was
right to be so goddamn obsessed with
that animal head in agatha's basement so
the official poster for this film filled
with hidden sightings of possible cameos
one additional sighting that we
overlooked until a high-res version of
this poster came out recently a broken
piece of glass right in the middle is
this fanged monster with a mouth and
eyes and flesh matching the appearance
of c'thun from the marvel comics c'thun
don't at me if you pronounce it choothon
or jonathan or chaithan jacobs euphoria
psycho this is a fictional name written
on the pages of comics based on
lovecraftian demonic names with way too
few vowels whose real pronunciations
would actually cause your brain to
explode if you heard them so let's just
stick with cathon thanks kevon is known
as the original author of the darkhold
and the demon who originally cursed
wanda maximoff with her witchcraft
powers when she was born and the fact
that he shows up on this poster is no
coincidence considering all the new
clues that we are uncovering from
trailer footage pointing to the darkhold
one is mcu origin and the witchcraft
elements from one division the tv spot
and online trailers show different
moments of wanda and america chavez in
this mysterious temple the back wall
resembles the page in the dark hold that
depicted the scarlet witch a top circle
with outward pointed triangles in a
sunburst pattern wavy lines laid over
that circle from the scarlet witch's
hair and below other circles inlaid with
sharp geometric angles america leaps off
an altar engraved with a horned animal
head like the animal head on the wall of
agatha's dungeon looks like a ram you
may remember how i interpreted it as the
satanic symbol of baphomet but this
curved horned animal is important
because it also shows up on the cover of
the dark hold two animal heads long
horns curved around as above so below
cathon is often depicted with huge
curved horns protruding from his head
just like this therefore this location
is 100 connected to the dark hole likely
the place it was written which in marvel
lore is a chamber on wounded gore
mountain other shots in the online
trailer in the tv spot show this
blizzardly mountainous location with a
shadowy structure and a nearby peak i
think that is the exterior of this
temple the chamber known as the dark
hold which gave the spell book its name
in the comics wunder gore mountain was
where in ancient times cathan who was
the eldest dark sorcerer on earth
inscribed all of his arcane knowledge on
scrolls made from indestructible
parchment and then he left to another
realm known as the flickering realms or
kalei then over the centuries any human
who came across the parchment gave up
their souls for its power and eventually
bound it together into a single volume
book calling it the dark hold meanwhile
kefan now a demonic spiritual presence
remained dormant in wounded gore
mountain the date of the modern era in
which the high evolutionary herbert
wyndham a geneticist villain highly
expected to appear in guardians volume
three maybe iwuji's character used wunor
mountain as the home for his lab where
he bred human animal hybrids called the
new men and it was here where a woman
named magda gave birth to twins wanda
and pietro maximon and the spirit of
kathan imbued his chaos magic into the
infant wanda so while wanda maximoff has
always been considered a marvel mutant
this curse from c'thon has always been
considered the origin of her sorcery now
the reason these videos are so detailed
folks is that i really just spent all my
time consuming content but the problem
is a lot of these streaming platforms
don't always have access to 100 of the
content that i know that they have which
is why i always boot up my streaming
platforms with expressvpn because using
netflix without expressvpn is like going
to a restaurant and only being allowed
to eat food on the left side of your
plate that's a lot of good food on that
right side that you're missing out on
netflix has thousands of shows and films
that you can't access based on your
location without expressvpn you are
missing out so thanks to expressvpn for
sponsoring this video expressvpn lets
you change your online location so that
you can access all the shows you want
get access to all that blocked content
open yourself up to whole new libraries
of content without having to pay for a
new streaming service just this week i
used it to watch the studio ghibli films
i just switched my location to the uk
refresh the page and i could watch
studio ghibli films for free our
european friends can do the reverse and
enjoy all of our us-only content i just
like how easy expressvpn is to use no
confusion no wasted time and the whole
thing runs fast you just fire up the app
and connect with just one click it is
the top rated vpn provider rated number
one by techradar so find out how you can
get three months of expressvpn for free
by visiting expressvpn.com new rockstars
or clicking the link in the description
below now the one division series hinted
at this backstory several times in the
episode eight flashback want to stop the
stark warhead from exploding using
low-level magic that she already had
years before her infinity stone exposure
did you stop that bomb
what you used a probability hex and when
agatha read the scarlet witch prophecy
from the darkhold it explicitly
mentioned that the scarlet witch was not
born naturally but an intentional
post-birth curse the scarlet witch is
not born she is forged
she has no coven nor need for
incantation your power exceeds that of
the sorcerer supreme it's your destiny
to destroy the world and the episode two
opening credits included the weird
easter egg of bova milk bova is the name
of the human cow hybrid on wunderguard
mountain who helped nurse wanda and
pietro as infants so all of this is not
just random stuff from the comics folks
these are major details from wanda's
origin that both one division and
multiverse of madness are adapting into
the live-action mcu to explain wanda's
present condition and the threats she
and doctor strange now face in this film
it looks like c'thun is gonna be
revealed as the original source of
wanda's chaos magic but in the mcu her
powers have expanded far beyond what
kathan likely intended because in
addition to her mutant status in the mcu
continuity she became a test subject for
hydra for infinity stone experimentation
her exposure to the mind stone was the
moment her sorcery amplified so that
only then she witnessed a vision of her
scarlet witch future so it was really
cathan's curse plus her mutant gene plus
cosmic radiation from an infinity stone
that resulted in her becoming a nexus
being one that can use the dark hole to
do what other dark sorcerers who bored
in the past could not to split herself
into at least two equally conscious
projected schrodinger selves and
navigate alternate universes within the
multiverse that perfect storm of
influences is what makes wanda unique
why the illuminati fears her so much and
why catholic has now returned to reclaim
his host perhaps even the voices of her
children that wanda thought she heard
was actually the voice of c'thun making
his first move and now here in the
second doctor strange film as the
actions of steven strange caused reality
to melt into dark matter beating on that
madness might be c'thun from the
flickering realms and now his well-fed
minions are spilling out of that
dimensional dam so back in wand division
yeah it was agatha all along in west
view but based on her worship of that
ram head she was likely one of those
many sorcerers over the ages who gave up
her soul for the dark hole's power that
is what her fingers fading to black is
all about it's a connection to c'thun
and the dark beings from his realm and
now that connection is carried by wanda
we can already see in trailer footage
how those stains start at just her
fingertips but then work their way down
her body cathon is back in control of
his host and multiverse of madness will
show us how that curse will have a
lasting impact on the multiverse and on
wanda's fellow mutants follow me on
instagram twitter at a boss following
your rockstars subscribe to directx for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you